ma nouvelle caisse
le kinder surprise de mes rêves
ouais oh putain
voici à quoi je ressemble quand je fais
de la corde à sauter
c'est aussi ça avoir un chat je vais
déballer ma nouvelle paire de shoes ah
bah non c'est pas la peine en fait c'est
déjà fait un Sergi enculer Norman? Ouais? ta pas une clope? si tien!
merci il paraît que les dj en concert
il simule du coup les mecs en fait
il pourrait faire ca bonsoir a tous,bonne soirée
supporter ça je te fais l'amour tout le
temps bon ok on apprend mais qui n'en
sais rien c'est le syndrome de michael
jackson ont arrêté sur le rappeur nul
tu parles trop mal anglais shawa et la
hype go to the god i'm an dans mes
céréales et du lait n'est pas trop
parce que prédit gère mal le nez non
on fait plutôt des blagues aux instits
qui parle arabe dit à roi maladroit
maroilles dit belgique à la baraque à
frites ce genre de mec qui parle trop
mal des meufs bondissait de meuf est
trop bonne une petite fuite des gros
seins trop trop bonne voie basse et ma
meuf
on sort ensemble depuis un mois à un
beau visage
attention imitations je suis jack
nicholson ce que les serveurs font à
chaque fois on voit tout ça pour dîner
on est deux vous êtes 2
norman norman nato et michel drucker la
normale d'un temps et mes putains de
bonnes meufs et marc michel raciste
après la victoire de l'algérie en
football c'est quoi ça c'est début
d'une émeute libère on appelle la
police
manquera pas dormir assez oh non c'est
juste mes cheveux pour c'est que ce mur
est vide pourtant il ya quelque chose
normale logiciel est normal
ouais on va en boîte ce soir pour quoi
faire mais pour liquider mais tonique et
des meufs c'est une peluche
ok si tu veux si tu veux or en bois tu
me files
ce soir on tourne en boîte norman
normes
le mec pas crédible qu'est ce qu'il ya
je suis un beau monde tiennent bien ta
gueule tu as construit ouais ouais c'est
ce qu'il a tort voici comment motiver un
homme à faire la vaisselle au nom tu
venais faire la vaisselle
c'est mort tu es sûr de bien skier
quand tu chantes tout seul c'est pas du
tout ce que tu crois et qui donne la
personne du roi
l'arroseur arrosé
le mec pas crédible 2 tu me prends de
vaud tu prends comme ça
ok je me bats pour voir oui je le crois
bonnier jir soit de poule
on a commencé c'est bien ensemble a
terminé ensemble offert putain mais
frères d'armes
rejoins moi chez moi
or